[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي احدث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى
البدايه من نيويورك جلسه مجلس الامن
المفتوحه بخصوص اقتحام وزير الامن القوميه
الاسرائيلي اتثمر بن غفير باحات المسجد
الاقصى في القدس المحتله
الى موسكو وقرار من الرئيس الروسي الذي
مركوتين بوقفه اطلاق النار في كل الجبهات
المواجهه في اوكرانيا ابتداءا من ظهري غدا
الجمعه وحتى منتصف ليله السبت
والى مبنى الكونجرس واخفاق جديد في
اختباري او اختياري رئيس جديد لمجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن نكرسي يتعثر في جلسه
تصويت ثامنه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
حزمه مساعدات الامريكيه جديده لاوكرانيا
بنحو ثلاثه مليارات دولار توصف بالاضخم من
مخزون البنتاجون وتتضمن 50 مركبه قتاليه
من طراز برادلي البيت الابيض يعلن واشنطن
وبرلين قررت تزويده بمدرعات قتاليه
والمانيا تعلن تقديم بطاريه صواريخ
باتريوت لاوكرانيا
عقبه محادثات هاتفيه بمبادره تركيه بوتين
يامر بوقت اطلاق النار 36 ساعه لمناسبه
عيد الميلاد اوكرانيا
يقول للجزيره انك
وشروطها لم تتغير بيضا يرى ان نفوت يسعى
الى متنفس
برلين تقول ان الخطوه لن تجلب الحريه ولا
الامان
بعد ايام من اقتحام بن غفير باحات المسجد
الاقصى مجلس الامن يعقد جلسه مفتوحه لبحث
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه في القدس اسرائيل
سيجال الازمه التونسيه يتصاعد نقابه
المحامين تتعهد بالتصدي لما سمته ضربا
للحريات والاستقلال القضاء
اتحاد الشغل يقول انه لن يقبل مقايضه
الاستقرار للاستداد
لضرب استقرار الدوله بتمويل خارجي
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا احدث حلقات الجدل المتعلق بالصين
والمخاوف من انتشار فيروس كورونا اكثر من
20 دول الى جانب جزيره تايوان قررت فرض
تدابير جديده على المسافرين الوافدين من
الصين
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه بشان حصيله ضحايا
الوباء التي
تقدمها الصين
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي برايكم ما هو حجمه التهديد القادم
من الصين بخصوص انتشار الهايروس
جاءت نتيجه تصويتكم على الشكل التالي نحو
40 في المئه قالوا ان التهديد كبير في حين
توقع نحو 22 في المئه ان يكون التهديد
محدودا بينما رجح نحو ثمانيه وثلاثين في
المئه عدم وجودي تهديد
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه هو يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
في بريطانيا
القطارات وفي فرنسا اطباء انقطاع الخاص
يواصلون الاضراب حتى الاحد
[موسيقى]
قال بين امريكيون الماني مشترك ان كل من
الرئيس جو بايدن والمستشار الالماني اولف
جولدز اكد في اتصال هاتفيه على ضروره
الاستمرار في تقديم الدعم الماليه
والانسانيه والعسكريه والدبلوماسيه
لاوكرانيا
والتجاوب العاجل مع طلبها بشان تعزيز
منظومات الدفاع الجوي لها في ضوء الى
هجمات الروسيه المستمره
كشف عن عزمي كلاب دولتين على تقديم
مساعدات عسكريه جديده
ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي وبطاريه دفاع جوي
اضافيه من طراز
بحسب البيان فانه واشنطن ستزود اوكرانيا
بنحو 50 مركبه من طراز برادلي في حين
ستقدم برلين مدرعه قتاليه من طراز
هذا وقد رفضك هذا الهدنه المؤقته التي
اعلنتها موسكو لمناسبه عيد الميلاد وفق
تقويم الكنيسه الشرقيه واعتبرتها ضربا من
النفاق متهمه موسكو بالسعي الى كسب الوقت
وقد امر الرئيس بلادي من بوتن جيشه
بالتقيد بوقف لاطلاق النار في اوكرانيا في
السادس والسابع من يناير
علقت برلين بالقول لان وقت اطلاق النار
الروسيه لن يجلب للحريه ولا الامان ام
الرئيس الامريكي
يسعى الى متنفس من خلال قراره هذا
30 ساعه من جانب روسيا بمناسبه عيد
الميلاد وفق تقويم الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
القوه الروسيه في كل الجبهات المواجهه
مدعوه بامر الرئاسي الى وقف اطلاق النار
بدا من منتصف نهار الجمعه حتى منتصف ليله
السبت قد لا تعني شيئا لكيف وحلفائها
رفضتها كما كان متوقعا وعلق عليها بلهجه
حاده مستشار الرئيس
الاوكرانيك
روسيا مغادره الاراضي المحتله وعندها فقط
ستنال هدنه مؤقته احتفظوا بالنفاق لانفسكم
ختم تغريدته قبل هذا القرار بساعات قليله
كان الرئيس التركي قد اتصل بنظره الروسي
محاوله اخرى من رجب طيب اردوغان من اجل
جمع الاضداد لانهاء الحرب
الرئاسه التركيه ان دعوات السلام والتفا
ينبغي دعمها بوقف اطلاق نار احاديه الجانب
ابلغه بوتن ان موسكو منفتحه على حوار جد
مع اوكرانيا شريطه
موسكو المعروفه والاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الواقع الجديد على الارض لاحقا عرض
اردوغان على الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي في
اتصال هاتفي التوسط في سلام دائما
مع روسيا بان بوتين يعرض على اوكرانيا
والعالم تحت كلمه محادثات الاعتراف بحق
روسيا في الاستلاف على الاراضي الاجنبيه
وهذا غير مقبول كما قال
عيد ميلاد بمراره الحرب وتدعيتها يحل على
المسيحيين الارثوذكس في روسيا واوكرانيا
تقل فرص انهاء القتال والحل الدبلوماسي
وتتدفق الاسلحه الغربيه على قوتك اكثر
فاكثر صلوات الكثيرين يوم العيد ستكون من
اجل من ماتوا ومن بقوا حتى لا يرحلوا في
معركه او قصف
الرئيس
ان على روسيا سحب قوتها واخلاق الاراضي
الاوكرانيه قبل الحديث عنه واضاف ان شروط
اوكرانيا لوقت اطلاق النار لم تتغير منذ
بدا روسيا حربها عليها
ومن الشمس برنامج
روسيا اثبات لحسن النيه ان تغادر الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وان تعود الى حدودها قبل
الحديث عن الهدنه نحن متاكدونا اننا سنحرر
اراضينا سواء بالوسائل العسكريه او
الدبلوماسيه
ينظم
مدير مبادره اوراسيا للديمقراطيه وابدا
معك سيد بيتر ما الذي يمنع كياف من
التجاوب مع الهدنه الروسيه 36 ساعه فقط
لمناسبه عيد الميلاد حسب التقويم الشرقي
ماشي ماشي
روسيا ليست شريكا يا حباب الثقه في عام
2014 و15 عند كان هنالك عروض لوقف اطلاق
النار خرقت روسيا هذه العهود التاليه
التاريخ يقولنا الان الثقه بيهم وايضا هم
مره اخرى يحاولنا ان يقدموا انفسهم على
انهم دعاه للسماء
اين كانوا عند في وقت احتفالات راس السنه
الميلاديه اين كان يخطفوننا هذه مجرد
اكاديميه ان يشتري الوقت لان يخسرون في
ارض المعركه التاليه حولنا القيام بكل شيء
ممكن من ينقط على اوكرانيا والعالم لكي
يجبروننا على الاستسلام اما عن طريق القوه
او عن طريق هذه المحاولات الفاشله
موسكو ليست جديره بثقه وتوتن يريد كسب
المزيد من الوقت بعدما عاناه جنوده في ارض
المعركه هذا ما نسمعه من ضيفنا في كيا
مرضه
انه عندما نتحدث عن
العطل او الاعياد وخاصه عندما نتحدث عن
فتره عيد الميلاد هذه لحظات ثمينه ونادره
علينا ان نضع جانبا كل همم
دعايات ولغه الخطاب القاسيه وعلينا ان
نتذكرنا اننا مسيحيون جميعا ونؤمن بالله
همم اليوم همم
الكرملين او ما يقوله الرئيس لكن علينا ان
نتذكر
نتذكر ايماننا وعن طريق رفض هذا العرض عرض
اللي وقفه اطلاق النار الام لا يتعلقوا
بالصراع بالصراع نفسه
ذا فويس
وليس في وجه الرئيس بوتن هذه هي الرساله
وربما هذه هي لحظه الحقيقه ان اوكرانيا عن
طريق رفض هذه الهدنه هي تكشف عن وجهها
الحقيقي
موجه للمسيح والمسيحيين وليس موجها للرئيس
بوتن ما رايك في ذلك باختصار ارجوك
سلم علي اقوله هو ان
اشير لكم وما قاله زميلي هذا هو قال انه
اذا اوكرانيا لم تقوم بذلك سيكون الصفعه
والبثقه في وجهي المسيحيين هذا سبب الذي
دفع الرئيس بوتن للقيام بهذا الامر لكي
يحاول ان يزيد من الضغط الامر هو تلاعب
يدعو للسخريه اين هؤلاء الروس الذين
يؤمنون بالله عندما كانوا يقصفون ماريوكا
من الجيد انهم الان قد صحوا من غفوتهم
يتحدثون عن الله عن الايمان من امرا يدعو
للسخريه في يوم عيد الميلاد
كثيرا في هذا الجدل اود ان اسال بشان هذه
الصفقات او بالاحرى هذه المساعدات حزمه
المساعدات الكبيره الا امريكيه والاوروبيه
التي ستحفظ
فيها اوكرانيا والتي همم كشفها بالتفصيل
البيان الامريكي الالماني الى اي مدى هذه
المركبات وبطاريات الصواريخ والدبابات
يمكن ان تكون عاملا مساعدا لكيف في ارض
المعركه
تدعو الى
التفاؤلؤ الولايات المتحده تعطي مدرعه
وايضا المانيا تعطيها ايضا معدات وايضا
همم دبابات ايضا هذا هو ما فهمناها ان ال
اوكرانينا كانوا يطلبون هذا الامر من
حلفاء معطونا الاسلحه لكي ننتصر في هذا
الحرب الاسلحه فقط هي التي ستجبر روسيا
على ان تاتي الى طاوله المفاوضات راينا
الان همم جبهه موحده غربيه حقا هناك من
المملكه المتحده وايضا المانيا والولايات
المتحدهمنا انه نفكر بدفاعه عن اوكرانيا
وان جعلها دوله مستقله مره ثانيه وانا
اطرب كل الروس هذا هو الذي سيؤدي الى وقت
الاطلاق النار بعد ان يغادر كل اي شبره من
العراق
هذه المساعدات بشكل سلبي على الجيش همم
الروسي في اوكرانيا وحلفائفه
همم
العسكري الاوكراني الروسي شيء بالتاكيد
انه اوكرانيا يلعبها الغرب لكن بدانا
نقاشه
لاعياد الميلاد
على الاقل يوم واحد
لسماح للمؤمنين بان يحتفل لكن من الذي
يتصف بالجنون ويستمر بالدعوه الى القتال
حتى خلال هذه 36 ساعه رساله
انا سالتك عن عن التعليق على هذه
المساعدات لانه الموضوع همم لانه الوقت
اصبح ضيقا
كويس
سالتك عن المساعدات العسكريه وتاثير هذه
المساعدات على الجيش الروسي في ارض
المعركه وخصوصا انها ااا تتضمن بطاريات
الدفاع جوي
ودبابات وغيرها
همم لكن انها تحاربو من الواضح ان
المساعدات الغربيه عنصر مهم جدا ولدي تسمح
لي الجيش الاوكراني بان يستمر وان يستسمح
لهم باطلاق التصريحات
والمطالبه
السيطره على
اراضي اخرى هذه هي ك همم كحبل الضغط الذي
يمكنه اوكرانيا من الاستمرار في هذا
الصراع لكن بنسبه لهذه المساعدات هيسا
ستنهار مره اخرى دعني اقول هذا ليس فقط
صراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا لكنه صراع بين
روسيا والنايتو وهو همم
اوكرانيا كامله
عن اهميتها ودورها المحتمل في تغيير مسار
الحرب
وننتقل الان مشاهدينا الى نيويورك جلسه
مجلس الامن الدولي بشان اقتحاماتي باحات
المسجد الاقصى
بالافعال
اوحاديه
غير مقبوله واشرنا ايضا الى ان منبر
الحكوميه
لرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ايضا
قد قال بانه سيلتزم بالوضع الراهن ونحن
نتوقع منه
الزملاء الاعزاء قليقون اذا توهرات في
خلال الاشهر القليله السابقه ونحن نهيب
بالاسرائيليين
الخطوات اللازمه من اجل استعاده الهدوء
وكذلك حفظ الارواح
من اجل تحقيق الدولتين علينا ان نحافظ على
هذه الامكانيه وعلينا ان نضمن ان كل
فلسطين
[موسيقى]
ازدهار على قدم المساوا شكرا سيدي الرئيس
اشكر مندوب الولايات المتحده على بيانه
واعطي الكلمه الان الى مندوب البانيا
الموقر
شكرا يا سيدي الرئيس
لقد
خلينا عاما كان يعقوب بالخطاب ملتهب الامر
الذي اودى بحياه الفلسطينيين وكذلك
الاسرائيلين في السنوات القليله الماضيه
وهذا انما ينمو على مدى تردى الوضع وعلى
الاترياق الذي ينبغي ان يقدم بشكل
نيه ونحن نرى ان السبيل الحالي لا يؤدي
الى الا الى تعميق انعدام التي الرئيس في
كل مره تتحدث فيها هنا حول مستجدات في
الشرق الاوسط تمت بعض النقاط وتمت نقطه
رئيسه الا وهي ان اي تدابير احاديه واي
خطوات تقود وتهيئه المناخ والبيئه اللازمه
من اجل تقري
سياسي من اجل السلامه فهي همم
فاننا وبدون وجود هذه الافاق فاننا نجد ان
الوضع مشلولا
والوضع اخذ في التردد هذا بالاضافه الى ان
لدينال ولكن هذه الامال بعد ان بعد
انصرامي عقدين
نجد ان هذه الامال باتت بعيده المنال اكثر
من اي وقت مضى تمت نقطه اخرى جدا مهمه
ونحن قد اشرنا اليها كثيرا وهي جد محوريه
ورئيسه في من اجل السلام وهي الحفاظ على
الوضع الراهيد الاماكن المقدسه الوضعيه
الراهن وهذا الخطاب
الى
المهالك في الحقيقه والذلك فاننا ندعو الى
الامتناع عن اي اجراءات من شانها ان
تنالوا من الوضع الراهن وعليه فاننا نؤكد
من جديد على موقفنا ثابت على اهميه
الحاسمه للحفاظ على الوضع الراهنه كده الى
مقدسه وهذه قواعد اتفق عليها اثر فان
وكذلك اتفاقات منظمه وينبغي ان تحترم ذلك
المقدسه وكذلك المملكه الهاش الاردنيه
تعاد وحسمه الاهميه من اجل ياسمين والامن
في المنطقه وكذلك لاشاعه الهدوء وفي هذا
الصدفه فقد احدنا علما بالتطمينات من جانب
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في الالتزامها اثاره
بالحفاظ على الوضع الراهن دون ادخال اي
تغييرات حين تعيش السلميه
يعد بالاستثمار في السلام وتوطيد اللحمه
سيدي الرئيس الوضع الراهن في الحقيقه يدل
بما لا يدعم مكان للشك الى ضروره عوده
الافقى السياسيه وذلك لم يتحقق الا من
خلال جهود حقيقيه من الجانبين كليهما
والالتزام بحلي الى دولتين على حدود سبعه
67 السلام بالنسبه لنا يعني اسرائيل تنعم
بالامن
وكذلك دوله دوله فلسطينيه مستقله
ديموقراطيه تنعم بالامن وكذلك حقوق
متساويه لكافه لشعبين يعيشان جانبا الى جن
في سلاما وا يتشاركان القدس كعاصمه مشتركه
لهم اي حل اخر خطير وغير مستدام وسيناله
فقط من اي افق لتحقيق سلام مستدامه شكرا
اشكر مندوب البانيا اللي موقر على بيانه
والان اعطي الكلمه الى مندوب
الاتحاد الروسي
دعوه الامارات العربيه المتحده والصين
لاقامه هذا الاجتماع في
الحاله
مجلس الامن المفتوحه والمنعقده
لبحث زياره او بالاحرى اقتحام وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيليه
للمسجد الاقصى هذه همم الزياره التي
اعتبرها مساعد الامين العام للامم المتحده
بانها تحريضيه لان بنغفير داعي لتغيير
الوضع
التاريخي للقدس كان لافتا نائب المندوب
الامريكيه لدى مجلس الامن الذي اعرض عن
رفض الاجراءات ال- الاحاديه التي تغير
الوضع همم
دعا الى الحفاظ على امكانيات حل الدولتين
كما اا تابعنا ينضم الينا للحديث عن هذه
الجلسه الدكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز همم
مسارات
لابحاث السياسات ومن واشنطن السفير بيجي
كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه
امريكيه يبدا معك سيد المصري
بالسؤال هل تتوقع شيئا استثنائيا من من
هذه الجلسه بالنظر الى المواقف التي تبعنا
جانبا منها قبل قليل
لا اتوقع شيئا استثنائيا ولكن سرعه انعقاد
المجلس والاذانات الواسعه التي سبقتها
تعكس مخاوف كبيره لدى المجتمع الدولي مما
يمكن ان تقوم به الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فبرنامج الحكومه
والبرامج التي اتفق عليها الكود مع
الاحزاب المشاركه بالائتلاف الحكومي
والتصريحات التي ادلى بها عدد من الوزراء
وخاصه من المتطرفين الفاشين في هذه
الحكومه جعلت المجتمع الدولي خلق جدا لذلك
نلاحظ ان الادانه يعني كانت اقوى من
الاذنات السابقه وبسرعه عقد مجلس الامن
وحتى الدول التي ترتبط يعني مع اسرائيل
بمعاهدات سلام لاحظنا انها كان لها موقف
يعني قوي يعني لدرجه ان الامارات شاركت
الصين في تقديم الطلب لعقد مجلس الامن وتم
الغاء زياره نتنياهو للامارات هذا يدل على
ان عالم يخاف من تطبيق الاهداف التي وضعها
الكثير من اعضاء الحكومه وهو تغيير
المكانه للمسجد الاقصى وفرض مساواه بين
المسلمين واليهود وهذا امر خطير جدا خاصه
اننا في العام الماضي لاحظنا ان اكثر من
51000 مستوطن يهودي منهم بعد رجال الدين
وبعد اعضاء الكنيسه دخلوا الى المسجد
الاقصى ومارسوا الطقوسهم الدينيه ورفعوا
الاعلام وهمم وقاموا بالغناء والرقص
ويمهدون لمساله التقسيم الزماني والمكاني
بشكل رسمي هذا ينذر بتدهور الموقف بشكل
كبير لذلك لاحظنا التحرك العاجل والاذانات
الواسعه طيب هذه الاذنات الواسعه حتى الان
ما زالت عمليا مواقف همم لفظيه لم يترجم
منها اي شيء على ارض الواقع سيد بيدجي
كراولي من هنا سال عن المو- ال- الموقف
الامريكي
تدعو الولايات المتحده لعدم تغيير ال-
الوضع الراهن الى عدم تقويض مساله حل
الدولتين وهو الامر الذي لا تلتزم به ااه
اسرائيل لا سابقا ولا ولا الان كيف ستترجم
الولايات المتحده مواقفها هذه على الارض
المتحده
خاص الى اسرائيل انها قلقه حول زياره ابن
كبير الى
المسجد الاقصى وهل احتماليه
اي تصعيجا للتوتر في القدس واعتقد ان انك
سمعت في اعلان
نائب
الامين العام في اجتماعي مجلس الامن قبل
دقائق اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده تعترف ان
حكومه اسرائيل هي
ضعيفه ان
نتنياهو قد يحاول ان يكسب دعم هذه وزراء
وهو يستمر بتغذيه هذه الغرائز المتطرفه
الموجوده لدى اعضاء هذه الحكومه نعم ولكن
يعني يبقى سؤالي موجوده هو نفسه التعبير
عن القلق ماذا يعني ما هي الخطوات التي
يمكن ان تتخذها الولايات المتحده بعد
التعبير عن القلق ما دام نتنياهو يسعى الى
استردائه وزراه دائما وهو ما يخالف الموقف
الامريكي
فيديو على ما الذي سيمضي فيه رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو قدما الامري يعود له لضماني ان
حكومته تحاول ان تتبع السياسات رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو قال سابقا انه يحترم
الوضع الحالي وعليه ان يوصل هذا الامر الى
اعضاء حكومته سيدان المصري هل تتوقع
هذه الجلسه والمواقف التي تعلم فيها ان
تترك اثرا على حكومه نتنياهو وعلى مواقف
هذه الحكومه ووزراءها بشكل او باخر
اعتقد انها ستترك اثرا خاصه ان حتى داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في حزب من الحسبين
المكونين لحزب هدات اسرائيل ادانت هذه
الزياره اذا كانت في اسرائيل كبيره هذا
يعني يمكن تخفيف يعني الاعتداءات على
المسجد الاقصى لامتصاص الغضب ويمكن ان
يكون التركيز على مواضع اخرى وهي المواضيع
التي ستاخذ اهتماما كبيرا لدى هذه الحكومه
وهو وهي استيطان وتهويد الاراضي
الفلسطينيه من النهر الى البحر كما جاء
يعني في بيان الحكومه بان هناك حق حصري
لاسرائيل في بناء المستوطنات في كل
المناطق بما في ذلك بالنقب والجليل وهذا
امر هو الذي سيحتل الثقه للاكبر مكانه
الاقصى منطقه حساسه يمكن ان يفكر مرتين
قبل ان يقوموا بخطوات كبيره يمكن ان يعود
خطوه الى الوراء من اج تقدم خطوات الى
الامام خاصه اننا همم سنواجه يعني مواعيد
حرجه جدا عندما يتلاقى رمضان مع لاعياد
اليهوديه وعندما تنفذ مسيره الاعلام في ال
19 من ايار القادم هذه مواعيد خطيره جدا
واذا لم يتحرك الوضع الدولي بشكل فاعل
لنجم اسرائيل وعزل هذه الحكومه واختها
لانني لا اوافق ان نتنياهو يريد بقاء
الوضع الراهن هو اخترق الوضع الراهن بشكل
كبير وبشكل كلي اثناء حكومته السابقه
ومستعد لمواصله يعني هذه السياسه خاصه انه
تحت تاثير يعني حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
المتطرف والذي هو بحاجه له من اجل اصدار
قوانين ستغير اسرائيل جزء احد اسباب قلق
العالم هذه الحكومه تريد ان تغير اسرائيل
لتكون بلادهموقراطيه ليبراليه لبلال دوري
محكمه العدل العليا وهذا يعني انها ستكون
اهلين داعشي وليس دوله يعني تدعي
الديمقراطيه اعود اليك بالجكاوي
هل ستؤيد الولايات المتحده قرارا
يدينوا زياره بنغفير مثلا او على الاقل
بيان من مجلس الامن يدين هل ستستغني
الولايات المتحده هذه المره عن الفيتو
ان هذا علينا ان ننتظر وننظر ما الذي
سيحدث وننظر الى اللغه البيان الختامي
الولايات المتحده قد استخدمت اما عن طريق
دعم او الامتناع عن التصويت عن البيانات
السابقه او انني في بعض الاحيان مثلا قامت
باستخدامه بطريقه
اختياريه
المتحده قد تكون متشككه حول ايداع ليس لا
يتم تلقي بشكل جيد في اسرائيل
له تاثير رمضان يتم الرغبه بتحقيقه انه قد
يقوي العناصر المتطرفه في حكومه الولايات
المتحده ربما تفضل ان تقول لتينيا هو انه
يتوجب عليه السيطره على هذه العناصر
المتطرفه في حكومته بدون ادامه
خارجيه الامريكيه من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
وشكرا للدكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات الابحاث
للسياسات كان معنا من رام الله
في التطورات على الارض شيعا مئات
الفلسطينيين في مدينه نابلس جثمان الشهيد
الفتى عامر ابو زيتون البالغ من العمر 16
عاما والذي استشهد فجر اليوم برصاص قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه اثناء اقتحامها مخيم
بلاطه شرقيا المدينه انطلق موكب التشييع
من مستشفى من مستشفى
مخيم بلاطه بالصلاه عليه قبل ان يبارك ثرى
في مقبره الشهداء في المخيم
[موسيقى]
يعرض برنامج الجزيره التحقيقي ما خفي اعظم
الذي يبث مساء غدا الجمعه لقطات ولقاءات
حصريه تكشف جانبا من كواليس كتيبه جنينه
تابعه لسرايا القدس الجناح العسكريه
للجهاد الاسلامي وايضا مجموعه عرين الاسود
من مواكبه شراره المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه وتمدودها على الرغم من الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي المتواصل لها وتعقيدات الامنيه
التي تواجهها يعرض تحقيق الذي يحمل عنوان
خارج الحسابات تفاصيل تنشروا لاول مره عن
بعض عمليات مجموعات المقاومه التي حدثت
مؤخرا في الضفه الغربيه
التحقيق الذي يقدمها زميل تامر المسحال
سيكشف ايضا جوانب خفيه من المواجهه
الامنيه المستمره على جبهات عذاب بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه والاحتلال ما خفيه
اعظم خارج الحس ياتيكم على شاشه الجزيره
ومن السطاتها المختلفه غدا الجمعه عند
العاشره وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
في تونس تصعيد لقبي ما تعمق الازمه في
البلاد فقد قال عميد المحمله التونسيين
حاتم ميزيو ان المحاماه ستتصدى لكل اشكال
الاستبداد ولن تقبل بالارتداد عن مكاسب
الثوره وفي وقفه احتجاجيه للمحامين امام
قصر العداله اعتبر عميد المحامين
التونسيين قانون الماليه الجديده تكريسا
لما دعاها املاءات صندوق النقد الدولي كما
شدد على ان المحامين التونسيين يرفضون
تبعيه القضاء لاي جهه سياسيه
هناك ارتدادات على مزار احترام الحقوق
والحريات هناك ارتداد على القضاء المستقل
هناك ارتداد على يعني مسارات
الديمقراطيه والتداول على السلطه ودوله
القانون المحاماه التونسيه لا يمكن ان
تبقى مكتوبه الاي دي عندما تضرب الحقوق
والحريات عندما يضرب القضاء عندما يبقى
القضاء خائف او يحكم وهو خائف اليوم
الاحالات
متعدده بالجمله واعدنا للاحاله العشوائيه
المراسيم الصادره مؤخرا تؤكد هذه
الارتدادات عن دوله القانون والحريات عن
مكاسب الشعب التونسي التي حققها في ثوره
2010 2011
من جانب قال الامين والعم المساعد للاتحاد
التونسي للشغل سامي الطاهري خلال تجمع في
جندوبه ان الاتحاد قدم مبادره للرئيس لكنه
لم يتفاعل معها واضاف ان موقف الاتحاد
الايجابي في التعامل مع العصابه الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو لم يكن صفا على بياض
وانما هو دعم النقدي مشروط بدعم الحريات
والديمقراطيه واعلائي سلطه القانون والفصل
بين السلطات واكد ان الاتحاد لن يقبل
مقايضه الاستقرار للاستبداد
في هذه الاثناء دعت احزاب التكتلات
الديمقراطيه والجمهوري والقطب والعمال
والتيار الديمقراطي القوى السياسيه
والمدنيه وشعبه التونسي الى التظاهر في
ذكرى الثوره يوم ال 14 من يناير دفاعا عن
استحقاقات الشعب الديمقراطيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والثقافيه حسبما اعلنت
تنسيقيه الاحزاب الديمقراطيه الاجتماعيه
في حسابها على فيسبوك
وكان الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد قال ان
الحريه لا تعني الفوضى وتامر على امن
الدوله الداخليه والخارجي حسب تعبيره
واتهم سعيد خلال لقائه وزير الداخليه
التونسيه جهات لم يسميها بتلقي مبالغ ضخمه
من الخارج وتوزيع اموال على المواطنين
لتعطيل الدوري الثاني للانتخابات مجلس
النواب وتعطيل بعض المرافق العموميه
لتاجيج الاوضاع وضرب استقرار الدوله
التونسيه حسب قوله
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا تعتزم الحكومه وطرح قوانين
لتقييد قدره النقابات على الاضراب في
مجالات حيويه بينها الصحه والتعليم
في بريطانيا
للعاملين في الطرق الرئيسه فيما تشهدوا
مناطق غرب لندن وجنوبها اضرابا لسائقي
حافلات النقل العام وسط المطالبات برفع
الاجور وتحسين ظروف العمل
تظاهر مئه الاطباء العامين في شوارع
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس للمطالبه بمضاعفه
رسوم الاستشاره الطبيه وتحسين ظروفهم
المهنيه رفع الاطباء متظاهرون شعارات تردد
بما اعتبروه تاريخيا من الحكومه في ايجاد
حلول جذريه للمشكلات التي يعانيها القطاع
الصحي
اطباء الطب العام يتظاهرون بالمئات في
شوارع باريس تنديدا باوضاعهم المذريه
ويتهمون سلطه لاشراف بالاستخفاف بمقاليبهم
الملحه تشير لافتاتهم الى ان الهدف من
الاضراب والتظاهر ليس المطالبا الماديه
وحسب من التنبيه لعواقب وضع المهني متى
ينظر بانهيار النظام الصحي الفرنسي برمته
مفعول الصدمه
التشغليه لدى الاطباء الشباب ونطلب من
الدوله توفير الاعتمادات اللازمه لتمكينها
من مواصله تقديم خدمات ذات جوده ورعايه
افضل للمواطنين
فرنسا يعتبر وان مشاركته في الاضراب حركه
نضاليه ضروريه لمكافحه ما يصفه بالتصحر
الطبي في الانتشار في فرنسا
عدد الاطباء متفاقم وتعتقد بسداد امكانيه
تعويض الاطباء باجراء الفحوص عن بعد
بتقنيات التواصل الحديثه من غير المعقول
ان تتجاهل الحكومه واهميه الطب العام لانه
في غياب شبكه عيادات طب عام من قويه
ستنهار المستشفيات العامه لانها ببساطه
ستعجز عن استيعاب جميع المرضى وفي خضم
الاضراب يشتد الضغط على العيادات التي
اثرت الاستمرار في تقديم خدماتها
وهذا يترتب عليه حتما الانتظار لمده
تتراوح بين 53 ساعات
مريض يوميا طيله الايام الماضيه ولم تتمكن
من الاستجابه لضعف هذا العدد من الباحثين
عن موعد مع الطبيب
اضافيه في فتره نعاني فيها اصلا من كثافه
بقى المهنيه
الحكومه الفرنسيه وعاربت عن تفهمها لمطالب
الاطباء لانها اعتبرت ان شنا الاضرابي في
وقت تواجه فيه المستشفيات الفرنسيه
والضغطا كبيرا امر غير مسؤول معلنه انها
ستقدم لاحقا خريطه طريق لتلبيه تطلعات
العاملين في القطاع الصحي يبدو ان هذا
الاضراب
ان الحركه النقابيه الاخيره الذي يشهده
قطاعه صحه الفرنسي في مستهل العام الجديد
حيث لوحه النقابات بتوسيع دائره المضربين
لتشمل القطاع الصحي العامه وهددت بخوض
اضراب مفتوح اعتبارا من العاشر من الشهر
الجاري لطفي المسعودي الجزيره باريس
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا العوده الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
التي سجلت فصلا جديدا من الدعم العسكريه
الغربيه
لاول مره بدبابات وعربات ثقيله بعد ان ظلت
شهورا تلح في طلب ذلك دون جدوى اعلنت
فرنسا انها ستسلم اوكرانيا دبابات خفيفه
من طراز اي ام اكس 10
بدا تصنيعها في ثمانيات القرن الماضي
ويبلغ وزنها نحو 25 طنا ومزوده بمدفع من
عيار
خمسه
لكن فرنسا لم توافق بعد على تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات
لوكلارك الاكثر تطورا ونجاحتا وهي مركبه
فرنسيه ثقيله يبلغ وزنه الواحده منها 56
طنا ويصل مدى مدفعها الى اربعه كيلومترات
كما تطلب قياس من المانيا تزويدها بدبابات
ليوبارد
اثنين هذه الدبابات ذات القدره القتاليه
العاليه فهي مزوده بمنظومه رؤيا وتسديد
تعمل ليلا ونهارا وتستطيع عبور الانهار
والقتال في مختلف الظروف المناخيه اما
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده تدرس
احتمال ارسال مركبات البراد للقتاليه الى
اوكرانيا وهي عربات قتال مدرعه ومزوده
بمدفع عن رشاش وتعتبر من الاليات الاساسيه
في الجيش الامريكي منذ منتصف 800 من
الاسلحه الامريكيه ايضا تطلب القياده
الاوكرانيه تزويدها بدبابات ابرامز وهي
دبابات قتال رئيسيه من الجيل الثالث تزن
نحو 63 طنا ومسلحه بمدفع عيار 120
ملليمترا ورشا
سلاح الدبابات تزداد فاعليه في الساحه
الاوكرانيه بغياب سلاح الجو الروسي شبه
الكامل عن الاجواء ويشهد تاريخ الحروب
الحديثه على ادوار استثنائيه قامت بها
الدبابات في ساحات وتواريخ مختلفه
استخدمت دبابات لاول مره في التاريخ عام
1916 خلال ما تعرف بمعركه الصوم في الحرب
العالميه الاولى بين القوات الالمانيه
وقوات الحلفاء واستخدمت فيها دبابات من
طراز 7 في الالمانيه ودبابات مارك الرابع
البريطانيا اما اكبر معارك الدبابات
واشهرها في التاريخ فكانت معركه كورس بين
القوات الالمانيه والقوات السوفياتيه خلال
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وقد دارت قرب
مدينه كورس جنوب غرب موسكو بين 58 دبابه
سوديتيه
250 دبابه المانيه واستمرت من الخامس من
يوليو حتى الثالث والعشرين من اغسطس عام
1943 وقد حددت مسار الحرب في النصف الثاني
من القرن العشرين تعتبر همم حرب اكتوبر
عام 73 من اكبر الحروب التي شاركت فيها
الدبابات حيث استخدمت مصر والجيوش العربيه
واسرائيل اكثر من اثنين 10,000 و300 دبابه
ومدرعه دمر نحو
الفين,600 منها خلال الحرب
مشاهدينا قبل الحوار مع الخبير العسكري
بشان المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا
نذكر بالبيان
الامريكيه المشترك الذي
قال هذا البيان ان كل من الرئيس جوبيدون
والمستشر
اكدال في اتصال هاتفي على ضروره الاستمرار
في تقديم الدعم المالي والانساني والعسكري
والدبلوماسيه لاوكرانيا في هذا البيان
هناك ذكر لمجموعه من المساعدات لا سيما
منها المدرعات وبطاريات صواريخ الدفاع
الجوي سنطلع على تفاصيلها مع مراسله
الجزيره في البيت الابيض وجد وقفي وجدي
اليك الكلب
نعم حسن طبعا هذا البيان المشترك الذي صدر
عن البيت الابيض
يؤكد في الرئيس الامريكي وكذلك المستشار
الالماني استمرار دعم بلديه مال لاوكرانيا
في مواجهه مواصفه البيان
حرب العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا طبعا في
هذه في هذا البيان ورد بان الولايات
المتحده سترسل للمره الاولى مركبات ابراج
القتاليه وهي تستخدم لسنوات من قبل الجيش
الامريكي هذه المركبات القتاليه مزوده
بالواحده منها رشاش وكذلك بالصاروخ مضاد
للدبابات وهي قادره على حمل 10 من الجنود
او من العناصر القتاليه الى ساحه المعركه
او منها وهي قادره على القيام بمهام
دفاعيه
وهجوميه في ان طبعا هذا من قبل من احد
مطالب الرئيس
الاوك نيوزلانكي عندما قدم هنا الى واشنطن
الشهر الماضي وهو تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ومركبات قتاليه لنقل الجنود استعدادا لفصل
الربيع الذي يتوقع ان تكون المعارك ان
تشتد المعارك خلال حسن طبعا المانيا من
جانبها تعهدت بتسليم اوكرانيا نسخه مماثله
النسخه الالمانيه المماثله لهذه العربات
القتاليه التي تستخدم ايضا من قبل عناصر
المشاه لنقل المقاتلين من والى خطوط
الجبهات خلال المعارك كذلك الجديد ايضا
بان المانيا تعهدت بالمثل مثل الولايات
المتحده وتعهد الامريكي الشهر الماضي
بتسليم اوكرانيا بطاريه باتريوت الدفاعيه
همم المانيا اليوم تعهدت بتسليم همم
اوكرانيا يا بطاريه باترويت ايضا بحسب ما
ورد في بيان البيت الابيض طبعا
عندما جاء زلنسكي كان مطلبه من قبل الرئيس
الامريكي وهو التواصل مع القاده
الاوروبيين من اجل الضغط باتجاه تزويد
اوكرانيا اسلحه متطوره
وليس اسلحه قديمه من الحقبه السوفيتيه
وواضح من خلال الاعلان الامريكي الالماني
المشترك ان الامور تسير بهذا الاتجاه حسن
رئيسيتان نوعيه هذه الاسلحه مازلنا عمليه
نتحدث عن كم كبير من الاسلحه لكن همم
تعتبر اسلحه دفاعيه اكثر منها
هجوميه باستثناء بعض همم الدبابات التي
يمكن استخدامها هجوميا لكن ما زال الاطار
المحدد من البيت الابيض ومن الاوروبيين
همم ما زال نفسه على ما نفهم
نعم وبالتحديد ربما الحديث عن ابرامز حتى
اليوم الولايات المتحده ترفض تسليم هذه
الدبابات لاوكرانيا ولكن
حسن الولايات المتحده تؤكد اكثر من مره
تحديدا البيت الابيض بان طبيعه المساعدات
الامنيه التي تقدمها لاوكرانيا تعتمد على
طبيعه الارض القتال كيفيه همم تغير او
تحول شكل العمليات القتاليه على الارض
وبناء عليها تجري تقيما همم للاسلحه التي
تحتاجها اوكرانيا في الفتره المقبله حاليا
في هذه الفتره في الشتاء ترى الولايات
المتحده ان اوكرانيا بحاجه
التي ارسلتها خلال الشهر الماضي هذه
البيتروت حاليا يتدرب عليها الجنود
الامريكيون وكذلك بحاجه الى هذا النوع من
العربات القتاليه الذي ايضا سوف يتلقى
الجنود الاوكرانيون تدريبا عليه
الجزيره من البيت الابيض
وينضم الينا من جناد على العقيده الكسندر
بوترابير رئيس التحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه سيده اليكساندر مرحبا بك
وضح ان هذه
المعدات التي اعلن عنها البيان الامريكي
الالماني انما هي تحضيرا لمعركه الربيع
يعني عندما همم تتغير ظروف المناخ
والاجواء هل يمكن ان تغير شيئا في ارض
المعارك
كمان
يؤثر على الوضع العسكري لان نوعيه ونوع
هذه المعدات التي وعد بتزويدها لاوكرانيا
ستغير قواعد اللعبه طبعا هي هي ليست اخر
ما توصل اليه التكنولوجيا في ترسانه
ولكنها حديثه ومؤثره والسبب في ارسالها
اوكرانيا الان بسيطه
لم يعد لديه ايه ذخائر من التي تتماشى مع
انظمه واسلحه
لهذا السبب الجيش الاوكراني بدا يتحول الى
معايير ومعدات النيترو طيب وهذه نقطه
سلبيه ام ايجابيه
الكويت
ايجابيا بسبب المعايير الجوده
هذه المعدات التي يمكن ان تستخدم بناء على
الوعود التي قدمت ستكون سيكون تاثيرها
اكبر بكثير مما كان مستخدم في المعارك حتى
الان ثانيا هذا سيسمح لاكرانيا بان لا
تتسلم معدات من فرنسا وامريكا فقط بل من
اي بلد ينتج معدات تتماشى ومعايير اسلحه
الفنيته همم
اذا اذا اردنا ان نسال
لعلك اطلعت على مضمون هذا البيان ونوعيه
الاسلحه والمركبات والدبابات اي اي منها
هي ال ال الاكثر تاثيرا في مسار المعارك
او يتوقع ان يكون لها الاثر الاكبر في
مسار المعارك على الارض لاحقا
[موسيقى]
من السلاح والتي هي ذات اهميه بالغه في
ارض المعركه اليوم وهما وحدات القياس التي
تقيس القوه الناريه واثارها في الميدان
ثانيا الوحدات المدفعيه
والدبابات بكل انواعها من الانواع الخفيفه
الى الانواع الثقيله وهي كلها موعوده ضمن
قائمه المعدات اذا سنرى حرفيا مئات مئات
من قطع على المدفعيه والتي يتم اخراجها من
الخدمه من بلداننا لفرنسا وغيرها وترسل
لفائده
شكرا
العسكريه السويسريه حدثنا من جنات
[موسيقى]
ويلات واسنان الحروب واشكال المعانات
الناتجه عنها كثيره ومؤلمه ابرزها بطبيعه
الحال الدماء التي تراق وفقدان
الاحبهم هربا من
المعارف
ربما بلا رجعه
بالاضافه الى التداعيه الانسانيه والمشاعر
السلبيه التي تخلفها الحروب تتواصل
التكلفه الاقتصاديه
وتداعياتها لسنوات طويله
ساعه الماضيه شهيده مؤشرات لاحتمال توقف
الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا ولو لساعه
محدده والامل كل الامل ان تسود في عامنا
الحلي الذي لم يكمل اسبوعه الاول بعد
اجواء سلام ومحبه عبر العالم وتغيب عنه
انباء الحروب والمها
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه دمتم بخير
[موسيقى]